[upbeat music]
(Ife)
It's been almost a year
since I've seen
my classmates.
It's been so long.
Everyone's gathered
again together
it's a great reunion,
yeah it's fantastic!
It feels like we never left
and at the same time it feels
like it's been a lifetime
since we've been here.
♪
(Won)
It feels a little surreal
to be back
I'm actually coming
from internationally
so to come all the way back
here and to have
wonderful people put
together this weekend for us
has been awesome.
[bagpipes playing]
[drumming]
[cheers and applause]
[band playing]
Hi!
Welcome back to Yale!
[applause]
[cheers and applause]
(President Salovey)
More than for having
your college years coincide with
a pandemic at its worst,
you will be remembered for
representing Yale at its best.
Today we salute your sacrifice,
sacrifice that has solidified
your rightful place
in history.
By the authority vested in me
it was my honor to
confer upon you the degree
as designated by the Dean
and admit you to all its rights
and responsibilities.
[cheers and applause]